all right what is wrong with you DJ what
alright so warm oh I can see the light
now review it ok ok no more goofing
around
we got a gamer mission to handle no
rising up gamers it's break time
we're only for the brain can be high oh
that was weird I actually expected to
feel your you're much smaller in the
game than you're a tree life I know yeah
ok now we need to do my one high five
[Music]
Samuel 20 Justin he looked right at you
sorry Samuel is he dead I think we
should stop wasting Emma
okay good idea thank you maybe we should
go in here oh I got it
after you sir all right oh look bring
them video game lobby
oh oh
okay I'll take the ammo
Oh put it off mo what where'd my gamer
ammo go I don't know oppa gangam there's
a feel like cleaning amnesia again bro
oh I hear people gamer you gotta join me
no no over here to the left of where you
came out left stop it already away here
okay
reach and clear all right get the other
side of me okay breaching clear I guess
okay oh she said there's other people I
hear my gameeee do something okay wait
wait okay am I definitely a.m.
it looks like you're sniffing your own
hand after touching your balls maybe I
am peek-a-boo peek-a-boo can you
actually drop your gun
I'm just gonna take my duck and go okay
there's a green boy shoot the green boy
came over just as you died yeah he
punched me how am I going to do what are
you gonna do okay okay don't shoot okay
okay okay got me dude Oh try and be more
of a gamer next okay we got a green one
coming he's dead nice looking nice
stupid
then I'm such a gamer nice yeah zombies
yeah you're a cool hat though he's so
Swedish really cool head okay I shot
this guy he's dead now don't ya this is
serious gaming so make love to the
zombies love take the series never kill
myself huh never joke about that kill it
okay there's a timer counting down I
think we have to fend off waves of
enemies Oh No take Adam nice I forgot
how to reload for a second oh okay
weirdo we're fine we're fine
epic we have 30 seconds everything this
is okay
oh that's a victory royale right there
I do cooperate what did cool gamers say
these days yes okay
behind you behind you yeah oh look at
these headshots you see in this bro oh
god watch out
do you feel like a gamer oh mama okay we
just have to walk on these it's one okay
dude flashlights pro-face flashlight
brothers eight No Oh does this creepy I
don't like this right okay
I don't think I want to find any in the
bathroom hey J Oh shootin some b-ball
it's really hard yes yeah
Oh VR is the future
oh there's a me watch this shoot him I
let you up nice oh you waste the three
shots where there should have only taken
you one no to four or five of them
coming Oh does one were you high okay
I'm gonna back it up a sec
can't see because I don't have the punch
languages Oh creepy okay you got that
yeah I just do a job for you okay so
what I waste the machine good I know how
do you feel you don't want to hit a
woman's that is true these zombies ain't
gonna know what hit them
hey zombies what hey what you got huh
ain't afraid
ooh that's Michael Caine another Naomi
okay now we can probably pull this lever
okay one minute go now I'm a comic okay
don't touch lights yeah
okay well there's a timer on this so we
might have to run now in a second oh
okay I'm running oh no my leg why do you
have legs should we go in here there's a
lot of dudes in the armory
your mom's in the armory oh geez you're
lucky I saved your ass after what you
said about maybe I kill them both
now you didn't yeah dead Oh does it go
down here oh you crazy
you should get this good nice oh oh hell
yeah auto shop oh yeah you just got sore
oh hey how you doing hey how would you
know if we don't make it out of here me
you smell like burgers what was that I
don't know what you are oh god I'm outta
ammo
oh no good good let us know where each
other is oh what's up Felix I'm trying
to run but there's some mini
she she's on your ass though Oh God
oh gosh ding ding link in description
I'm comment like subscribe like a Bosch
[Laughter]
boss like a boss and then you win like
this video to save you